Eliot ... Laura ... Anna et Chabi, c'est ça ?
Vous avez déjà fait un "escape" ?
Hm non, mais par contre je suis hyper balaise en énigme.
Ça va être un petit peu plus dur qu'un Picsou Magazine tu sais ?
Vous allez être enfermés pendant une heure dans une pièce et pour en sortir, vous allez devoir réussir votre mission.
On a un miroir et on a la lettre de la comtesse qui dit "Je ne les supporte plus, j'ai envie de mourir".
Donc vous allez avoir des indices qui vont vous permettre enfaite de découvrir ... Des énigmes.
Pour vous menez jusqu'à la solution finale.
C'est censé faire peur ton truc ?
Ouais... Vous allez flipper ouais.
C'est bon, j'arrête ce jeu de merde là, c'est bon !
Je veux sortir !
Je suis blessée, je veux sortir !
Non ! Attention !
Mais elle est complètement tarée cette fille !
J'ai pas envie de crever ici moi !
Non arrête !
Pourquoi elle répond pas ?
Bon et bien ... Bonne chance !
Vous allez en avoir besoin.